i need you to explain fabi's last move  to me if it's not a  sport malfunction oh wow i guess it  isn't  he just played rook to f1  well he wanted to make space for his  bishop  there you have it  can we zoom in let's just  if this is not a computer move nothing  is  oh it's just a normal move now you  prepare because page one of the knight  is first  yeah but usually they don't well  we spent 45 minutes it's unlikely he's  still  still in prep no but i mean the idea  itself right probably he's seen it  somewhere else that rook f1 and then  people can think about it oh he forgot  to pick the king first  looks like someone who plays online for  the first time and tries to move the  rook first and then surprise the king  can't jump over  no but this is just  prophylaxis i mean  it just wants to stop manage for you and  the rook on g1 wasn't better